magic do as you will
the last unicorn this has been on my
list to do for a while i wasn't sure
when i was gonna get around to it but i
feel inspired because
if you weren't aware peter s beagle
writer of the original novel and
actually the screenwriter for this
animated version
has been touring the film around and i
actually got to see it
on the big screen which i've never
gotten to see and hear him talk about
the writing of it the adaptation of it
if you're like me you grew up on this
movie
find out if it's coming anywhere near
you and if there's stops left and get
tickets also inspired by that experience
i have now actually read the book which
i did not do
i grew up in this movie but i never read
the book and i have not read the book
and it's wonderful and amazing
and also another thing i'm going to
recommend for anyone who likes the movie
but
i got to set those things aside and
really just talk about this film
on its own merits as best as i can
having now had these experiences the
last unicorn tells the story of
the last unicorn in the world who sets
out
to try and find out what happened to the
rest of her kind and along the way she
picks up some interesting companions has
some adventures
the film that has certain elements of a
road trip movie it has it has tons of
elements of fairy tale which is
ultimately what it is
now this film dates back to the early
80s and when it was done by rank and
bass now at the time that they did this
they had already done their adaptation
of the hobbit and it's very much in that
same
visual vein and visually this movie
is gorgeous the sophistication of the
animation is not as high as you would
get from something like
disney they didn't have the time or the
money to afford quite that high quality
of
animation but the quality of the designs
and the artwork
is just stellar a lot of the animators
who worked on this
would later go on to form studio ghibli
with hayao miyazaki and work on many of
his films
and you can see that same level of
commitment and integrity in the
art and the design seriously you can
freeze frame almost
any random second from this film and
it's just a gorgeous
image even though the smoothness of the
animation itself
is not the highest quality in the world
the voice cast is really stellar in this
film as well there's mia faro playing
the unicorn
and she has a bit of a tricky job
because the unicorn is
sort of ethereal a little bit detached
but she still is able to bring
just enough sort of warmth to her voice
into her performance that you
feel for her and you care about her
because she could have come off
frankly kind of [ __ ] in the hands of
an actress
who didn't get the character another
really big highlight though
has got to be schmendrick the magician
who's voiced by alan arkin and he
is just wonderful alan arkin has this
wonderful sort of
low-key delivery that just really suits
a magician who is
bad at his job and that is exactly what
schmendrick is
he has high ambitions he wants the world
but he's just he's not
very good and he knows that there's some
other great voices in here as well
angela lansbury really going against
type as the witch mommy fortuna she's
oh she's creepy and then there is the
incomparable christopher lee as king
haggard now
his voice casting i think was really key
and quite essential because
king haggard actually has a pretty
interesting and detailed kind of
backstory and history to him but the
film doesn't have time for that i mean
this
this was done as a children's film and
it's got a pretty tight run time but
his voice and the way he delivers lines
and just sort of the weight
of what he has to say and the way he
says it says
a whole lot about the character that the
film didn't have time to
set aside and say okay here's what he's
about and in many ways ellen arkham
brings the same thing to schmendrick
where he's able to
give you a whole lot of information
about this character and about this
character's history just the way that he
says stuff
i also want to single out a character
who i especially now appreciate
more as an adult which is the character
of molly grew she's voiced by an actress
by the name of tammy grimes
and she is she's a character who really
is in there for the
for the adults because she's passed her
prime and
her reaction when she first sees the
unicorn is
anger because you know the legend is
that unicorns are supposed to come to
young beautiful pure maidens and she's
not
that she hasn't been for a while and she
is so
angry that the unicorn would dare come
to her when
she is old and past her prime and it
kids may not quite get but
as an adult now it's a really powerful
moment and the character is just
delightful anyways
there's also the music now the music is
honestly a little bit of a mixed bag the
songs that are good
are great the main title song the last
unicorn
is a stellar song and it's perfect for
this movie then there's another song
also early on called man's road
which is also just great for setting the
tone of what's going on and
sort of getting you into the mood for
everything that's going to happen
unfortunately the songs aren't quite as
good in the latter half
just in general but also for another
reason which is that
some characters start actually singing
and that hasn't happened up to that
point first half of the movie first two
thirds really
the songs just play in the background
and they sort of serve to
overcut almost kind of montage type
things and then
when the characters start bursting out
into song it
it comes out of nowhere and
unfortunately the actors who sing
i don't want to say that they've got bad
voices but it's very clear they were
cast for the quality of their acting not
the quality of their singing voices
which sort of leads me into the
what is the main weakness of this film
which is that its first half
is much stronger and much more
interesting than its second half is
now having now read the book i can
confirm what i had long suspected which
is that the second half
works very well on the page because
basically what happens is that
the characters sort of get to where they
said they were going to go
a little bit past the halfway mark and
then the
story goes into basically a lengthy
delay
stalling the climax now it works in the
book because
we're given some really heavy insight
into these characters and
and getting really down to the meat and
bones of what it is that's going on with
them
here it's more surface level on surface
level it reads kind of corny kind of
cheesy thankfully it does not completely
fall apart the latter half is carried by
i i mentioned already christopher lee
but there's also some really stellar
stuff with a cat
and a skull which are just wonderful
moments that help liven things back up
again for
a pretty strong finish at the very end i
will say that
don't be shocked if younger kids sort of
fade out on the latter half of the film
and also i suppose it's worth mentioning
that if you're particularly sensitive
about what your kids see
this was made back in the early 80s
where the standard of gpg
was not exactly the same as it is now so
there are a few i guess what you would
consider scary moments and there is
some use of the word damn but for my
part i think the strengths are strong
enough that it carries through
and glosses over the weaknesses it's not
a perfect film but i think it's a film
that was done with a lot of love
it's a wonderful story it's very well
cast and as i said even though the
actual
quality of the animation movement is not
the highest the the images
are stark and they stay with you and
they just they're beautiful
so that's my take on it have you ever
seen the last unicorn if you did
what were your thoughts on the thing did
you love it did you hate it whatever it
is you thought
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it as for me
i'll be back as soon as i can get my
next fix